[Music]
I said a prayer I'm like I know I'm
going to heaven I hope my kids are okay
my husband Kim Kardashian opening up on
The Ellen DeGeneres Show for her first
interview since her terrifying Paris
robbery I don't want to start crying by
like I feel like that was so meant to
happen to me like I'm such a different
person and like I'm just don't want to
start crying anymore but um yeah I could
you can cry it was it was meant to
happen to me like the things I really
feel like things happen in your life to
teach you things I was definitely
materialistic before and not that
there's anything bad with having things
but like I'm so happy that my kids get
this me and that this is who I'm raising
my kids cuz I I just don't care about
that stuff anymore Kim K also came to
her mom's defense getting candid about
Caitlyn Jenner's tell-all book where she
bashed Kris Jenner my heart breaks for
my mom she sang all these things and
it's just I don't think it's necessary
you know and I just feel like it's
unfair things aren't truthful I'll
always love her I just feel like I don't
respect the character that she's showing
now and the reality star dished on her
kids unique personalities and ongoing
sibling rivalry I mean like North just
beats him up all day long and he so
doesn't cry what way does she beat him
up she's just awful she it's like she is
so jealous and it's I thought it was a
phase it's not going away but she is
Kanye's twin same personality really is
the same wild thing like she those two
[Music]
you